meanwhile russia's foreign ministry has
summoned the eu's ambassador to russia
over what moscow calls a blockade on
goods transiting through lithuania to
the russian exclave of kaliningrad
lithuania halted the rail transit of
goods including construction material
metals and coal after a new package of
eu sanctions against russia came into
force late last week kaliningrad is
wedged between nato members lithuania
and
poland russia's security council
secretary warned lithuania of quote
serious consequences if the ban isn't
lifted well here's what the lithuanian
prime minister said in response
lithuania has no interest in escalation
but the sanctions must be implemented
it's ironic to hear russia accuse us of
international treaty violations because
i don't know if there is any
international treaty that russia itself
hasn't violated
dw's russia analyst and former moscow
correspondent emily shervin is here with
more
the lithuanian prime minister they're
not
very um well worried apparently about
those threats um how concerned should
the west be about this warning well the
secretary of russia's security council
warned of serious consequences uh for
the lithuanian people without saying
what those consequences would actually
be we heard from a lower level official
the governor of the region of
kaliningrad who actually said that one
potential response
could be that russia could limit the
transit of lithuanian goods in a kind of
tit-for-tat response but of course the
language that we're hearing especially
higher up in the food chain as it were
in the kremlin is much more dramatic so
i mentioned the security council
secretary he framed all of this as
essentially the next step in nato upping
its presence at russia's borders he said
that it's an example that you cannot
trust the west
even with written promises and of course
this is all happening as well against
the backdrop of kind of combative
language language in general we heard
vladimir putin himself talking today
about the deployment of new air defense
systems and ballistic missiles so it all
sounds pretty dramatic but i would guess
that it's more
rhetoric bluster than anything else
what is moscow trying to achieve here
well it's part of you know a wider push
um in russia to get eu sanctions lifted
and to paint them as destructive so the
governor of uh the region of kaliningrad
who i just mentioned said that these new
measures would suffocate the region he
said that over that around 40 to 50
percent of cargo will be completely
stopped by these measures um and you
know the fact that they're calling this
a blockade you know has echoes of the
siege of leningrad world war ii tragic
events um in world war ii i think this
is a part of a wider effort to put
pressure on the west to lift sanctions
in general you might remember that putin
has been calling for sanctions to be
lifted that he's been saying that that
would make it easier to solve the food
crisis
we've had recently the russian energy
giant gazprom
kind of reducing its shipments of gas to
germany via north stream won the
pipeline saying that it's due to
technical difficulties which were caused
by sanctions so it's kind of part of
that wider effort i think to to put the
pressure on the west and to and to get
those sanctions lifted now give us a bit
of context on a geopolitical scale how
important is kaliningrad well it's uh
it's an enclave in the baltic sea uh it
includes a very strategic port baltisque
which is the headquarters of the baltic
sea fleet and also is the westernmost
point in russia and now of course
specifically you know with the war in
ukraine um
russia has been painting this conflict
in a way as a conflict a wider conflict
between russia and the west so the fact
that the enclave is kind of sandwiched
as we saw on that map between nato
states
makes it almost the you know the
battleground for for that conflict as
well for the west between the western
russia at least that's how russian state
tv is portraying it dw's russia analyst
emily sherwin thank you so much for
those insights
i'm joined now by our correspondent
constantine edgard in lithuania
constantine good to see you so we've
just heard the lithuanian prime minister
say they have no interest in an
escalation
how concerned are they though in vilnius
of that happening considering the
country's geographic position of course
pablo people here are concerned 24 7.
people in the baltic states including
first and foremost of lithuania consider
themselves to be on the front line and
uh in this respect there is concern
about possible russian action but i
think the fact that the eu ambassador
was called into
the foreign ministry in moscow uh for
explanations probably shows that moscow
will have to
uh basically admit the reality what
lithuania did is part of the uh european
eu sanctions the fourth package adopted
quite some time ago and there was no way
lithuania could not uh not uh do that uh
and could not block these specific goods
from transit i have to say that other
goods and people can still transit
moreover i'll add to that that military
transit which is
effectuated between
russia by belarus to kaliningrad still
continues it is subject to a special
bilateral treaty between lithuania and
russia and there was no disruption there
as for the measures that uh russia can
impose on lithuania well there is
actually not much that can be done
probably they can prevent lithuanian
citizens from traveling to cleaning
ground but there are not many of them
frankly speaking so it will be difficult
to imagine what kind of major
pushback
the kremlin could invent
well kaliningrad has a large port
constantine is it not possible for goods
to enter and exit on cargo ships
well they do and actually the governor
of kaliningrad oblast has called on the
russian government to give more money to
buy or to to basically to introduce more
ferries on uh on the road between
kaliningrad and the main russian port on
the baltic which is called ust lugar
that's not far from st petersburg
i suppose that this will be in the end
uh the decision although it may not be
uh it may be quite costly to bring let
us say steal our uh ferrous metals uh
on the ship it's definitely much more
costly costly uh but
if russia wants to continue doing that
then it will have to do it i think there
is just no other way
constantine eggert in lithuania thank
you
thank you
you